je suis ici afin de d'écouter les
Québécois et de donner un plus grand
voix à leur préoccupation on a besoin
des Québécois j'adore le Québec et je
serai le Québec aura une grande présence
dans mon gouvernement dans le
gouvernement poilievre du futur
[Musique]
son intérêt sa passion pour le Québec et
ses objectifs pour la province dans le
cadre de la prochaine élection le chef
conservateur y était en tournée cette
semaine pour rencontrer les électeurs et
échanger la perception qu'ils ont de lui
et du Parti conservateur est-ce que ça a
fonctionné voyons voir ce qu'on pense
mes collaborateurs est animateur de midi
info et si première Chantal Hébert et
chroniqueur au Toronto Star et le
magazine L'actualité Michel COG et
chroniqueur politique à La Presse et
Radio-Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour
Alex est-ce que ça a fonctionné les
trois jours que Monsieur poignet va
passer
on a une petite côte à remonter quand
même où est-ce qu'on en est maintenant
si c'était aussi facile que de séduire
une province en trois jours d'autres le
référence ça va non c'est ça ça prend du
travail quand on est d'abord un député
et politicien de l'extérieur du Québec
ça prend plus de travail soyons honnête
là il y a une barrière d'accent une
barrière de langue les Québécois ça
demande est-ce qu'ils nous comprend
vraiment même s'il vient de l'extérieur
donc c'est un travail de longue haleine
jusqu'à présent pierre polliève parle de
sujet assez cérébraux ne touche pas
beaucoup le cœur les émotions des
Québécois donc on porte assez peu
attention l'impression est aussi qu'on
est à plusieurs mois au moins peut-être
même plus d'un an d'un élection donc on
est dans le travail de fond là on est
dans la préparation du terrain on n'est
pas du tout dans je vais commencer par
par cette zone de québécoise on est
vraiment dans comprendre le Québec
rencontrer des groupes des chambres de
commerce des organismes communautaires
qu'est-ce qui préoccupe les Québécois et
tant mieux s'il fait des entrevues des
points de presse au passage ce qu'il ne
faisait pas avant mais préciser qu'on
est rendu quelque part je pense qu'on
est à peine parti j'attends la suite
j'attends
dans le moment les Québécois sont en
train de se magazine le prochain
gouvernement fédéral donc pour la
plupart ils sont pas en train de suivre
à la trace puis à poilue dans la trace à
partir de la colline parlementaire je
vous inclus ont dû trouver qu'il y avait
eu un changement de personnalité en
traversant la rivière des soutabouais
quand même parce que tout à coup il n'a
pas été question de ce que tout était
brisé au Canada et il y a quand même
ralenti un peu sur ses attaques quand
Justin Trudeau peut-être parce que
quelqu'un s'est aperçu dans son
entourage que de traiter Jean chagrin
ancien Premier ministre comme un moyen
de de faire à peu près la même chose
avec à l'intérieur ce qui avait plus de
tirant d'eau ici qu'il en aura pour
l'avenir prévisible et le fait que
Justin Trudeau est néanmoins un premier
ministre dans la base sélectorale est au
Québec ça voulait dire que ça commençait
mal pour Monsieur poignet au Québec et
c'est d'ailleurs la au Canada ou ses
affaires vont être plus mal dans les
faits si vous enleviez le Québec ou le
ramener ou même niveau même
concurrentiel comme en Ontario entre les
libellules les conservateurs les
libéraux seraient en immense difficulté
c'est le Québec et la grande région de
Toronto dans le moment qui garde le
Parti libéral à flot dans les intentions
de vote et qui font que c'est pas dans
le sac une victoire pour des
conservateurs alors moi je m'attends à
voir Monsieur paulive revenir
régulièrement question à 100 000 $ votre
être capable de présenter une équipe
digne d'occuper la grande place qui le
promet au Québec au sein de son
gouvernement la grande question c'est
prédécesseurs ont eu de la difficulté
là-dessus Michel il y avait il y avait
une grosse il y a quand même une côte à
remonter monsieur pollièvre il est pas
particulièrement quand on quand on
regarde les sondages la reconnaissance
des Québécois pas de son côté on n'est
pas particulièrement non plus un lien
avec certaines de ses priorités
qu'est-ce qu'il doit faire pour percer
au Québec
dans cette tournée là il y a beaucoup
passé de temps avec les militants
conservateurs et c'est pas pour rien le
parti notre conservateur au Québec n'a
pas aimé et puis un poignet va pas voter
pour Pierre poignet bon il y a eu un
député qui était apprécié qui a
démissionné à cause de ça alors il y
avait des Bleus qui se demandent c'est
qui cette babyte là ce que c'est
compatible avec nous est-ce que cette
personne là peut faire quelque chose
pour nous alors il fallait d'abord
qu'ils se reconnecte avec son parti ça
veut dire des assemblées à trois via des
choses comme ça il y a donné quelques
entrevues aussi ou d'ailleurs des fois
il était un peu étrange je sais pas si
c'est la barrière de la langue même
moment donné ça avait mal commencé cette
phrase là ça partait des Banques
Alimentaires dit les gens les plus
pauvres demandent d'aide médicale à
mourir c'est c'est ça fait un peu zombie
ça fait là il va falloir ça aussi la
prochaine visite là bon là vous aurez la
porte le recrutement Québec Chantal vous
avez évoqué certains liens entre
particuliers
des gens de la carte qui pourrait être
intéressés ou qui ont à tout le moins
peut-être une conversation préliminaire
est-ce que c'est là sa victoire elle
passe par là ou ça c'est ça qui donne à
Monsieur poignet pour éventuellement une
équipe qui se tient au Québec
le seul chef non élu au Québec comme
député qui a gagné une majorité de siège
au Québec depuis Pierre Trudeau dans les
années 60 s'appelait Jack letton et
qu'est-ce qui a été l'élément
déclencheur qui a amené les électeurs au
Québec à reconsidérer le NPD c'est le
recrutement de Thomas malkeur
dans le code et il fait aucun doute
d'ailleurs que le Parti conservateur de
Monsieur Poirier au Québec a
désespérément besoin de figure de proue
autre que celle qui l'a déjà qui ont pas
à part Gérard Deltel on peut pas dire
que ce sont des vedettes de la politique
ce que ça veut dire et c'est ça qui est
malaisant pour le Parti conservateur ça
veut dire aller dans l'étape de la carte
on fait bien une candidats et
effectivement il y a des stratèges
conservateurs au Québec qui rêvent de
voir des ministres bien en vue de
François Legault faire le saut en
politique fédérale
la troisième fois on va vendre au
Québécois ce qu'on vend au Canada au
Canada anglais c'est la bonne approche
d'après vous
regarder la dizaine de députés au Québec
si on n'avait pas mis de l'avance ces
propositions là on ne le sait pas on
aurait pu tomber à deux trois députés
donc pour l'instant on n'est pas on
n'est pas en mode séduction plein gaz
sur le Québec mais ce qu'on
reconsidérera cette idée là pour
l'instant c'est pas dans les plats mais
moi je pense la porte est pas fermée ok
j'entends je vous vois réagir
du Québec lavande s'annonce difficile
entre autres là on pense à l'idée de
démanteler l'infrastructure de l'auto
changement climatique de Justin Trudeau
se débarrasser de la tarification du
carbone construire plus de léodure
desserrer le contrôle des armes à feu
bonne chance pour la vitrine
conservatrice parce que c'est ça que le
Parti conservateur offre Québec des
nouvelles d'aliments de l'aide médicale
à mourir et ça continue et ça continue
donc
facile à dire c'est vrai que ça a pas
marché et effectivement la recette selon
ça ne marcherait pas si bien que ça mais
à la fin le Parti conservateur parce que
les conservateurs sont au pouvoir en
Ontario et que ça risque de coûter des
votes à Pierre poillière donc il peut
pas gagner comme Steven Harper en disant
avec 5 6 sièges au Québec je vais être
correct c'est plus compliqué que ça pour
lui parce que c'est pas garanti non plus
en Ontario du film de l'impopularité
possible des conservateurs provinciaux
dans cette province ou ailleurs c'est
une équation qui est potentiellement
compliquée on n'est pas encore près
d'une élection mais ça s'en vient on
préfère les choses une chose dont on est
prêt par exemple ça semble être le cas
c'est une entente en matière de
financement de la santé en tout cas si
on écoute tout le monde cette semaine
province fédérale vous allez entendre un
extrait de Jean-Yves Duclos vendredi
Michel je reviens avec vous
[Musique]
je suis effectivement optimiste parce
qu'il y a eu oui un changement de temps
mais certainement aussi un changement de
direction au cours des dernières
semaines je crois que tout le monde
maintenant s'entend et compris les
premiers ministres que l'on doit
travailler pour les résultats qui sont
importants pour les travailleurs et pour
les patients
Michel bon on a entendu ça cette semaine
on a aussi vu des de gros problèmes dans
les urgences à Montréal dans le nord du
Québec d'argent c'est c'est la solution
d'après vous
c'est certainement une partie de la
solution au soldat de la guerre et ça
fait des années que les premiers soient
raciaux disent il faut une augmentation
substantielle des transferts fédéraux
votre part glisse d'année en année et là
c'est plus possible pour nous de
continuer comme ça alors il y a une
pression énorme il faut le noter de des
électeurs de l'opinion publique qui voit
son système de santé pas juste au Québec
d'ailleurs en très mauvais état il y a
des endroits où par exemple on dit bon
on va faire des déchirures privées
l'Ontario par exemple si la solution
maintenant qu'on serait aujourd'hui mais
enfin on essaie toutes sortes de choses
c'est parce que le système va pas bien
et là si le gouvernement fédéral faisait
comme d'habitude dans ce dans ces
situations là et de dire non ça nous
prend des normes nationales et on aurait
intégré tout le monde puissent que on
aurait eu une attente de 10 ans encore
une autre fois donc cette pression là
elle existe sur fédéral autant que sur
les provinces et c'est ça qui est un
moment donné fait que on est plus proche
d'une entente cela dit sur du Clos aussi
a dit dans la même conférence de presse
c'est encore beaucoup beaucoup de
travail à faire donc c'est pas encore
réglé comme du papier abusé
de montant il y a pas des chansons non
plus on sent juste que on est dans une
meilleure position qu'on était avant
Alec et est-ce que est-ce que ça va
contribuer ou est-ce que ça peut donner
vraiment un coup de barre dans le
système une éventuelle entente avec
plusieurs milliards de dollars de plus
et régler des situations qu'on en a vu à
Montréal cette semaine par exemple
en fait c'est la fondation
dont les provinces ont besoin pour être
capables d'appliquer certaines réformes
parce qu'il faut par exemple Christian
Dubé voudrait bien inventer des
infirmières c'est ce qui manque le plus
au Québec et qui fait en sorte qu'on a
des situations comme ma maison neuve
Rosemont cette semaine mais il peut pas
en inventer il doit en former davantage
pour informer davantage ça prend quoi ça
prend plus de locaux plus de professeurs
plus de mentors et ça prend comme on l'a
annonce au Québec il y a un an des
bourses pour attirer plus d'étudiants
dans le milieu médical mais ça prend de
l'argent pour ça bonifier les conditions
de travail est capable de diminuer le
ratio infirmière patient éventuellement
prendre embaucher plus ça fera plus
d'argent donc c'est pas c'est pas
l'argent qui va régler le problème c'est
l'argent qui va permettre d'avoir des
réformes qui se tiennent plutôt que
d'avoir des réformes sur papier qui vont
nulle part alors oui ça prend un peu
plus d'argent les montants qui circulent
en coulisses sont intéressants le Québec
voulait 6 milliards par année on pourra
aller chercher jusqu'à 4 milliards et
demi par année on obtiendra pas les 6
milliards voulu c'est normal dans une
négociation on obtient pas tout mais si
on allait chercher un montant dans dans
ces ordres là en moyenne sur 10 ans et
là après ça il faut être capable de
livrer la marchandise mais au moins la
fondation
largeable ça on verra ce que chacune des
provinces en font là je suis en train
d'expliquer là c'est que ça va prendre
du temps et le lendemain de l'Entente
dans un nouveau monde et où tout peut
devenir possible tout ces choses là vont
prendre un certain temps et ce que ça
veut dire c'est que en gros
les provinces seront pas dédouanées
d'essayer des nouvelles façons d'arriver
à un système qui est plus performant
c'est pas la première fois que le
gouvernement fédéral met plus d'argent
en santé le fait en 2004 pendant 10 ans
12 ans ça a été prolongé n'entendent de
10 ans en 2004 en passant avec fort peu
de conditions et
on nous voici où on est avec des
problèmes qui ressemblent mais beaucoup
à tous ceux qui avaient été prévus par
les 56 000 études qui ont été faites
pour cette ronde de négociation là alors
si l'argent réglé les problèmes les
provinces pendant une grosse partie de
ces années-là ont reçu des augmentations
de transfert qui étaient au-delà de
l'inflation
puis nous voici en 2023 en train de
rediscuter la même chose c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que
il y a 10 ans le MPD fédéral avait dit
on retire notre appui un gouvernement
minoritaire libéral parce que il laisse
passer des privatisation de la santé
dans certaines provinces cette semaine
Jacques Médecin exactement la même chose
alors surveiller un peu l'état de la
relation NPD
Justin Trudeau parce que Monsieur signe
pourrir c'est être trouvé une nouvelle
raison d'être plus indépendante et plus
autonome je vous dis pas que ça va lui
donner les clés du 24 soit sec ou de
quoi qu'on les veut pas faire ça mais la
dernière fois ça a donné les clés du
pouvoir à Steven un peu vite pour de NPD
mais néanmoins des bruits qu'on peut
capter dans la position néo-démocrate
font état d'un refroidissement des
relations dans la foulée d'une entente
du genre de celle dont on parle de cette
semaine effectivement
[Rires]
on va voir ce que l'on entendra sur une
éventuelle entente au cours des
prochains jours Alex Chantal Michel
bonne fin de weekend